欢迎来到书卷声播
今天我们要深入探讨一份非常有趣的资料
是来自一场叫做巨人节XJoman
顶尖交易员的思维对谈的现场问答精华
我们今天的任务是想带你走一趟顶尖交易员的内心之旅
从他们如何建立信念开始
接着看他们在市场风暴中如何求生
最后再深入到他们是如何透过自我对话
来克服心魔
如果你也对投资交易感到好奇
想知道高手是怎么思考
怎么控制风险
又怎么调整心态
那最实的内容
你绝对不能错过
没错
而且我觉得啊
这份资料最珍贵的地方
在于它不是要给你任何名牌
对那种东西没有意义
嗯
它真正要揭示的是一种思维框架
或者说一套世界观
它涵盖了从研究方法
风险控管
交易心理学
到对市场的根本观点
可以说是一趟非常全面的
顶尖交易员心法之旅
好的
那我们就从很多人最好奇的问题开始吧
就是要怎么抱住
一直从400块
一路涨到4000块的股票
这听起来
嗯
有点像天方夜谭
这背后到底有什么秘诀
是靠看筹码
看基本面
还是有什么神器的EPS估算公司
诶 巨人节啊
他的答案非常直接
甚至我觉得有点让人绝望
他说全部都要研究
全部
对 全部
他强调抱住一个大波段的单子
那个信心绝对不是来自单一面向的决策
那种信心是建立在非常非常多面向的研究之上
而且关键是
这些资料还要持续更新
全部都要研诱
这听起来工程浩大
也跟一般人想的很不一样
很多人都希望找到一个圣杯
一个简单的指标或公式
最好是可以无脑存寻的那种
他正好就对这种心态
提出了一个非常严厉的境遇
他说
小心那些试图用单一公式
解释世界的人
他讲得更白
如果有人告诉你
靠某个技术指标
某一条神奇的线
或者是一个像ABC123
这种简单的公式
就能解释所有行情
解决所有问题
那个人绝对是骗子
这话说得很重
但也很有道理
就有点像
你不可能只用一个温度计
就想预测全球的气候变迁一样
是的
就是这个意思
真实的市场维结构
那个real market microstructure
是极其复杂的
牵涉到成千上万的参与者
跟他们的心理
对不对
这不可能用单一公式去概括
所以它更在乎的是心态的建立
而不是去专研某一个单纯的K线技术
你的信心必须来自于
你对资讯掌握的完整度
而不是对某个公式的迷信
刚刚讲的研究要全面
不要相信单一公式
但这就让我很好奇了
现在的市场
我们研究做得再好
速度好像也比不过AI
比不过那些高频交易
就是HFT
在这种机器当道的时代
我们人类特别是散户
还有生存空间吗
短线交易是不是真的要被淘汰了
这里就提出了一个非常关键的概念
它称之为肉
肉 吃的那个肉吗
对 可以这么想
就是利润的那个肉
我们常说的α
它的观点是
人类的优势就在于机器尚未完全覆盖的领域
如果兼比的是报价速度
是毫秒之间的价差
那人类绝对赢不了机器
没错
就像资料里说的
一个再厉害的棒球选手
也绝对打不赢一台设定好球速跟角度的发球机
跟机器比速度是自寻死路
那这个肉具体来说是什么
听起来有点抽象
我们要去哪里找这种演算法还没吃光的利润
你可以把这个肉想象成市场上还没被标准化的机会
高频交易很会吃那些标准化的利润
比如说微小的价差套利但人类的优势在于判断那些无法轻易量化的事情像什么比如一间公司的长期竞争力
一个产业的典范转移
或者是一个管理层的诚信跟远见
这些东西充满了模糊地带
就是机器比较难抓到的肉
所以对资金比较小的投资人来说
是不是就该放弃短线
专心找这些肉
他有提到
转去做波段或长线
像巴菲特那样追求富力
当然是可行的
但这里有个非常大的前提
也是多数人做不到的
是什么
就是你必须能忍受无聊
忍受无聊
这点真的太难了
市场每天都在波动
社群媒体上每天都有人分享
又赚了多少
手上没单子
或是抱着不动的股票
真的会很焦虑
完全正确
大部分人撑不住
就是因为想求快
无法忍受长时间的等待和持有
但顶尖交易员的思维是
如果这个战场
也就是短线交易
它的规则对你不利
那就换一个战场
而不是硬要在原地被机器屠杀
好的
那假设我们研究做好了
也找到了自己的肉
但市场总有意外
万一发生了胖手指这种操作失误
多按一个零之类的
或是券商系统突然当机
导致你无法平仓
眼睁睁看着亏损扩大
该怎么办
关于这种极端状况呢
它有一套非常清晰的SOP
也就是标准作业流程
SOP的第一步
也是最重要的
马上停损
如果你的系统还能动
还能砍仓
那就什么都不要小
立刻执行
但最怕的就是系统卡住
或是部位太大
流动性不够
想砍也砍不掉
那时候该怎么办
这就是SOP的第二步
锁端或对冲
这个时候你思考的第一件事
必须是解决生存问题
利用你手上的备用金
现货部位或是去期货市场
进行反向操作来对冲
先把亏损锁在一个固定范围内
锁单或对冲听起来是个很理想的做法
但这对一般散户来说
操作门槛是不是很高
它可能需要有期货账户
还要能瞬间反应过来
这在极度恐慌下很难做到吧
的确有门槛
但这里的核心原则是
先生存再处理
就算你没办法做到完美的对冲
重点是采取行动
去阻止亏损的无限扩大
哪怕只是卖掉其他获利的股票
来筹错保证金都行
原则就是
先确凿自己不会违约或破产
明天太阳升起时
你还活在市场上
再来慢慢处理那个烂摊子
先活下来最重要
处理完当下的危机
事或检讨就非常关键了
但这又带出了
另外一个经典困扰
我明明每次赔钱都有检讨
为什么下次还是继续赔钱
我要怎么知道
我的检讨方向是正确的
这里的观点我认为是
这次分享中最颠覆
也最有价值的一点
巨人杰认为
检讨没有对错
只有对对手的揣摩
对对手的揣摩
这点真的颠覆了我的想象
我一直以为交易检讨
就是打开Excel
看看K线图
适合诸葛说
哪里进场点不好
哪里停损色态劲
但他们却把重点
放在对手身上
这几乎是把技术分析
拉高到了心理战的层级
没错
他分享自己十年前
常常被市场上
所谓的嘉义帮修理
哦 嘉义帮
这个有在看盘的人
应该不陌生
对 就是指市场上那群
以短线当充文明
资金实力非常雄厚的主力
所以你看
他的做法不是只看线图
而是去研究
为什么他们会赢
他们的手法是什么
他们的惯性是什么
他检讨的对象
不是抽象的市场
而是活生生
有特定手法的对手
所以他提出的检讨流程
重点就不在图表
而是人
完全正确
他提出一个
三步骤的检讨流程
第一
问自己为什么进场
这很基本
第二
问出炒是否符合原定策略
这是在检讨纪律
但第三步也是最关键的一步是问是谁赚走了我的钱凭什么凭什么哇对你必须去想象一幕对面那个
把你钱赚走的人
他看到了什么
你没看到的资讯
他用了什么
你没想到的策略
交易是跟人在博弈
而不是跟机器打分数
这才是检讨的真谛
讲到博弈
心理层面真的太关键了
这就让我们来聊聊
周门的例子
资料中有人问他
他是如何抱住台积电
从600块高点精力几乎摇斩
再一路抱到创新高的呢
这中间的心态转折是什么
周门的方法可以归纳成很实际的三点
第一点是生活观察法
他说他的同学很多都在台积电
或相关供应链工作
从他们优渥的生活
不断扩厂的现实
就能亲身证实
这家公司的竞争力是真的非常强
这给了他最基本的持股信心
这听起来很像传奇基金经理人
彼得林区的策略
从生活中找好公司
但会不会有盲点啊
毕竟我们生活圈有限
看到的可能不是全貌
甚至可能有同温层效应啊
当然有
所以这只是他信心的来源之一
而不是全部
你看他马上就接了第二点
叫做检查清单
哦检查清单
对
这就是把感性的观察
拉回到理性的框架里
他会问自己两个非常简单但强大的问题
第一
当初买进的理由消失了吗
答案是没有
公司基本面依然强劲
第二
市场上有没有出现更好的标的
可以让我把资金移过去
答案也是没有
这两个问题其实就是一道防火墙
避免你因为单纯的感觉良好
就一直抱下去
那第三点呢
我觉得这一点在社群媒体时代
可能是对每个人最大的考验
是的
第三点就是噪音管理
他说股价在跌的时候
网路上所有人都在骂他是韭菜
后来涨回来了
又变成骂他嚣张
他很早就学会了远离这些网路上的评论
关掉APP
回归到自己出处的研究
和那份检查清单上
这样他能不受市场集体情绪的
剧烈干扰
这就引出另一个
很有趣的矛盾点了
很多人都说
做交易要像个机器人
保持中立
无感
才能理性决策
但巨人节却反其道而行
说要对亏损有
很大的感受
这样不会更容易产生得失心
反而做出错误的决定吗
他的观点是
你必须拒绝麻木
拒绝麻木
对
因为他说
你亏的每一分钱
都是辛苦钱
你必须打从心底看中你的亏损
如果你对赔钱没感觉
觉得啊反正就是个数字
那你就永远不会认真去寻找自己交易系统里的漏洞
所以痛感反而猜是进步的真正动力
不是应该要避免它吗
完全是
它对比了两种心态
如果你对亏损无感
你就会一直重复犯同样的错误
这就叫白牌赔钱
Vain Loss
白赔了
对
但如果是他的心态
对亏损有强烈的痛感
那个pain
这种不甘心的感觉
会逼迫自己去修正
force correction
最终才能优化策略
找到新的alpha
所以痛感其实是一个讯号
告诉你这里有问题
快来修好它
而不是一个需要被压抑的情势
哇这个解释很棒
简单来说
就是对赚钱要保持平常心
但要把对亏钱的不甘心
转化为砖研跟剪头的燃料
正是如此
那如果市场行情真的很差
熊市来临
不管用什么策略都找不到肉
一直被市场修理
这个时候该怎么办
是把资金停泊在像是美债这种
比较安全的资产吗
他的答案很简单
也充满了智慧
他说如果没有行情
或者找不到适合自己的策略
那就休息
休息就这样
就这样
听起来很佛系
但这可能也是最难的
因为市场每天都在那里诱惑你
手上每单子看着别人长
真的会手痒环境或商品测薪不符合他的预期他宁愿空手就像资料里那张图说的position 0peace of mind 100
部位是零
心灵瓶颈是100
对 有时候不交易
才是最上等的交易
那么当他决定要交易时
落实到具体的台湾市场
他的观点是什么
例如如果真的找不到
好的个股T-type品
他会去买项0050这种大盘指数吗
感觉很安全又分散
这里他就点出了一个
他认为的台湾市场的结构性现实
哦 是什么
就是台积电大于一切
他比较了美国的S&P500指数
前十大公司的占比相对分散
而且成分股会轮动
但在台湾的0050指数中
光是台积电一家的占比就超过60%
但对很多不想花时间研究个股的人来说
买0050不就是为了分散风险吗
他这样直接说不如买台积电会不会有点太武断了
他的逻辑是这样
当一个成分股占比超过一半时
这个ETF的分散效果就已经大打折扣了
所以他的结论是买台湾的指数也就是0050
等于是买了台积电plus一堆表现比台积电弱的公司
哇
在这种特殊的市场结构下
他认为直接买最强的那家公司
也就是台积电
可能还更有效率
这不是说0050不好
而是点出他在台湾市场结构下的真实样貌
这确实是非常务实
甚至有点残酷的认知
那么在研究上
他的视野会看多远
只看未来一两年吗
他的答案是研究无上限
他的团队有大约十位研究员
研究各行各业
而且完全不会局限在
只看一两年的财报
资料中举了一个能源题材的例子
他们从2023年就开始布局
着眼的却是三年以上的全球事件性
哇
他的动见是
市场的定价随时在变
一个题材可能很快就被消化完毕
所以你的研究必须永远
跑在市场反应之前
不能被特定的时间框架给限制住
哇
今天聊下来
我感觉脑袋里多了好几个
以前从没想过的观念
如果让我来试着总结一下
我们从这份资料中提炼出来的核心思维
我认为有三个最重要的心法
嗯
你说说看
第一是
全观的研究
这点是所有信心的基础
不迷信单一指标或神奇公式
而是把筹码
基本面
总体经济等所有资讯都纳入考量
你的信心来自于你资讯的完整度
没错
第二个呢
第二个
我觉得最震撼的是痛苦的检讨
你必须记住
交易是人跟人的博弈
所以每一笔亏损
你都不能轻易放过
要去问
是谁赚走了我的钱
他凭什么
去揣摩对手的思维
才能让你真正的进化
而不是在同一个地方
把拔摔倒
这个总结得很好
那第三点呢
第三者
则是现实的认知
就包含了两个层面
一承认人类在速度上
绝对输给机器
所以你的战场要去寻找机器
还没完全覆盖的肉
二要承认你所在的市场的
结构性现实
像是在台湾
台积电的巨大影响力
就是一个你无法回避的现实
你的资产配置
就必须把这个因素考虑进去
嗯 完全正确
最后 巨人节有一句总结的话
我认为非常深刻
他说 交易没有名牌
只有对市场无止境的理解
以及对荧幕背后那个对手的揣摩
这句话说得真好
这也留给你一个可以回去好好思考的问题
下次当你分析一笔交易时
除了问 接下来价格会怎么走
或许可以换一个更强大
也更困难的问题
这笔交易的另一端是谁
他此刻正在想什么
谢谢大家的聆听
如果有想听哪本书
可以在下面留言
谢谢大家
我们下次见